welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to Kevin Feige has
just done his first ever ask me anything
on Reddit and the creator really went in
depth on things in the MCU as well as
how the franchise could operate going
forward throughout this video I'll be
breaking down the major point of his
interactions and what they hint at and
confirm I'll leave a link to the thread
in the description if you want to read
the entire thing but right now I'll just
be covering the big questions that were
asked this is full spoilers ahead so if
you're not completely caught up to
endgame there may be some reveals that
you don't want to know so I highly
recommend that you turn off the video
now but without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of Kevin Feige SatAM a ok so
the first question came from rode to
love who asked how much will the Disney
Plus shows weave into the films
obviously this is a big point of
contention at the moment with Loki
surviving endgame and going off
somewhere by himself
Feige replied to this saying totally and
completely which means that we can take
that Loki will be going forward doing
his own thing that will eventually tie
back into the overall door of the series
in addition to this Scarlet Witch and
vision show of one division will likely
pick up on their relationship though
rumor has it that it's set between the
period of Civil War and end games foggy
also stated that the one-shots will be
making a transition to the service which
I'm sure many can't wait to see now on
to quite a sad question
Feige did say that Stan Lee did not get
to see a final cut of endgame this is a
huge bummer but the comic icon did at
least get to find out what happened in
the story with foggy stating Stan loved
to wait to see the final movie at the
premiere so unfortunately he did not get
to see the finished movie Stan got a
download of the full story the day he
came and shot his cameo so at least he
did get to find out what happened to his
beloved creations it just sucks he never
got to see on the big screen when asked
if he would ever cameo in a Marvel movie
Feige said
I don't like being on camera but I did
cameo in a deleted scene in the first
x-men as a Weapon X technician I was
completely covered in herd masking
goggles so it doesn't look like we'll be
seeing him take over the Stanley role of
making a notable cameo in each movie
which two it's a bit of a shame whilst
it wasn't asked me anything foggy as
always didn't play his hand too much and
when asked if he knows if cap was always
the father of Peggy's kids even in
Winter Soldier he said yes that's it dig
give any details away just yet to me at
least I think cap is which is why Peggy
looks so shocked during her fade-out and
states you look so young
haven't seen him through the years this
would be a surprise for her so I'd like
to take from this that the two were
always together in regards to the second
snap Dee Wallace 3099 asked people have
expressed views that in endgame those
brought back by the snap could have died
in accidents like someone being brought
back 100 feet in the air where a plane
used to be is it possible that Hulk when
doing this snap not only brought
everyone back but also brought them back
in a safe place to which fire you
replied we refer to the version of Hulk
in endgame as smart Hulk so yes in
regards to plans for the future
Feige stated that they always plan five
years ahead but that it often extends
much further
it just isn't laid in stone this is
backed up by another answer in the
thread in which he states that they knew
about adapting the Infinity Gauntlet way
back in 2012 whilst making the Avengers
which is why Donna's cameos at the end
of the movie
other notable points are that [ __ ] he
loved into the spider verse and out of
all the actors in the MCU he had to
fight the hardest to have Robert Downey
jr. cast his Iron Man he also said that
in age of Ultron Captain America was
worthy he just didn't want to make Thor
feel bad and if he could go back and
change everything it would be the dying
of Thor's eyebrows in his solo movie and
those are the main points from the
interview obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on what the creator said
and what your favorite thing was if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the top 5 band theories for
spider-man par from
which would be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you